(crowd cheering)
- Thank you.
- Yeah. You smell good.
- How are you?
- I don't know what your, your scent is
but it smells very good.
- Oh. Thank you.
You know, I try, I like
rotate scents a lot.
And right now I'm wearing two-
- Oh I do that too.
- so I'm wearing Te Matcha and Another 13.
- Yeah, you blend.
I like blending as well.
Just like wine.
(crowd laughs)
- Just like wine.
- Yeah. How are you?
- I'm good.
- I feel like you've been
with us since the beginning-
- I know.
- since like the pilot.
- I was talking about
that in the car over.
I was like, I remember when
we did the pilot so long ago.
- I know.
- Yeah.
(crowd clapping)
- You believed in us
before other people did.
- Well. Yeah, duh.
- I was very excited.
Anyway, do you have any big
like holiday plans this year?
- I mean, I love the holidays in general,
so I feel like even like, honestly,
I was watching Elf yesterday, last night.
(crowd laughing)
- Love Elf.
- So very excited.
But this year I'm gonna go skiing.
Haven't been skiing for
the last couple years,
so really excited.
- Are you able, 'cause I,
even if I do like this show
or the Voice, they always
make you sign waivers.
- They always tell you not to.
- Yeah. And they're like, you can't do it.
And then first of all,
I'm like, look at me.
Like do I look like I'm
about to jump out of a plane
or something?
- I mean, maybe.
- I'm not that person.
- Kelly Clarkson, heli skiing.
- Nope! Nope.
Not in, I used to
snowboard, which I liked.
- Oh yeah?
- But I didn't like skiing.
- You fall a lot more.
- Yeah, but I got a lot of padding.
(both laughing)
I just, no, it's just like
even when I was like thin
and fit, I got a big old behind.
I didn't mind falling on it.
But like your legs going in
separate directions, scared me.
- Yeah.
- I mean, yeah, I, I agree.
Technically I'm not allowed to do it
if I'm on contract at all,
which is why I haven't
in the last few years.
- Yeah.
- And then this year I'm
like running to go do it
because I'm not on contract,
which means I can legally do it.
- Have a life?
(everyone laughs)
- But I, yeah, I skied since
I was like three years old.
- Wow.
- So I'm used to, you know,
having the sticks on my feet.
- I have my kids, they're
we, I have a ranch on Montana
and my ex too, we get
them skiing all the time
and I'm like-
- That's beautiful.
- skiing or snowboarding.
It's so fun to be active.
You're very active.
- Yes.
- You, I think you love a
lot of dangerous activities.
- I do love dangerous activities.
- What is that?
Why?
(crowd laughs)
- Another thing that I'm
not allowed to do ever,
on contract, is ride
anything with two wheels.
That goes for bikes,
motorcycles, dirt bikes.
And so obviously, this
year I was off contract
and I was like, I wanna ride dirt bikes.
So I've started riding dirt bikes
(crowd cheers)
which my mother's not very happy about.
But I really enjoy it.
- Actually that was the
first thing I ever got on
when I was a kid.
Somebody had a dirt bike
and it was the first thing
I ever did, like motorized.
- Yeah. We had four wheelers.
- So I, we didn't have that.
It was like a friend thing.
But now I was gonna say
they said two wheels. Are
you allowed to four wheel?
- So the four wheel, I feel
like you can get away with
a little bit more 'cause it's
like an all-terrain vehicle.
- Yeah.
- But the two wheel is just
a little bit of a death trap.
- Yeah.
- They frown upon it.
- For obvious reasons.
(both laughing)
- Yeah.
So wait, speaking of
motorsports, we saw this photo.
- Yeah.
(actress laughing)
- That so. What, what are you doing there?
Was it like a test? A dare?
If you could hold it?
- Oh, for sure.
No, I mean I, I went to
the Austin Grand Prix.
- Yeah.
- Which is like the the
Circuit of the Americas,
which is really cool,
with Williams racing,
and I wanted see if I could pick up
the tire 'cause it looked really heavy
and I did it and it wasn't
quite as heavy as I expected.
- Oh wow.
- But it was fun.
- Was that so much fun?
- Yeah, it was a lot of fun.
I really, really love, I love Formula 1,
especially since the show on Netflix-
- Yeah.
- got really into the drivers
and knowing their kind
of backstory. It was-
- I love how active you are.
You love to just be so
active and out there.
- Yeah.
- You like adrenaline, you like the rush?
- I do like adrenaline. Yeah.
- I'm so opposite.
- I would totally drive a
Formula 1 car if I could;
if I possibly was allowed to
- I would totally cheer
for you from the side.
- From the side?
(crowd laughs)
You can be the checkered flag.
- I will be your water girl.
- You can have the checkered flags.
- I will hold down that water bottle.
You're like, I'm so thirsty. I've got you.
(both laughing)
- I've got you.
- I'm not into, I did
the NASCAR thing once
and they drove me around.
It was Jimmy Johnson and it was so fast.
I was like, we're good.
(crowd laughs)
- They go really fast.
- Yeah, they do!
- And it's like the G4s from the circle.
- Yeah, they do.
- Yeah that's scary.
- And I was like, Jimmy,
Kelly's not so into that.
(everyone laughs)
- So what, you also posted this photo.
Let's see this photo.
- Yes. Oh my god.
Yeah. Have you ever gotten in these?
- Oh, well first of all,
are you broken here?
(actress laughing)
Like what's happening?
What is, no, what's happening?
- That's a cast, a double
leg cast for my dirt biking.
(crowd laughs)
No, no, no.
That is basically they're
they're like these Normatec boots.
I call 'em my puffy pants.
But you get in them and they
have like chambers of air
and they like flush your like lactic acid
in your legs and stuff like that.
- What?
- So you can work and do things all day
and your legs, by the
end of the day they hurt,
you put these on and
they don't hurt anymore.
(Kelly gasps)
So when I'm working and
like traveling for work,
this is like the perfect thing.
You'd love them.
- I'm gonna get into that.
So it's just air
basically like circulation
and stuff Like that.
- Yeah. It's lymphatic
drainage is basically the idea.
- Okay. That's really good for you.
- Yeah, it's great for you.
Which I also swear by.
- Totally getting myself
that for Christmas.
(crowd laughs)
So the new show is based on
a famous Sci-Fi novel right?
- Yeah.
It's based on a book by William Gibson
who is kind of known as
like the godfather of Sci-Fi
in a lot of ways.
- That's exciting.
- It's really, it's a
really wonderful show
and it takes place around a
young girl named Flynn Fisher
who's in a small town in
the Appalachian Mountains.
- Yeah.
- And basically she plays
video games for a living
to be able to make money
and she uses other people's avatars.
And one day she has the
opportunity to beta test
a new headset from a
very mysterious company
and she puts the headset on
and she realizes that
she's not operating a game
but she's actually operating a robot body
in the future in the year 2100 in London.
- It's so interesting.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Is this why, 'cause
this is your first TV
kind of thing, right? Or
like episodic thing right?
- Yeah. That's my first TV.
Yeah. Pretty much ever.
- Yeah. I love that you chose this.
So like you love gaming though
too, in real life, right?
- I do, yeah. I do love gaming.
I think there's a lot of
parallels between my character
and myself in this show in a lot of ways.
And gaming is a huge one.
I've been a big gamer
since I was really young.
I have four brothers and like,
I couldn't physically overpower them-
- That'll do it.
- But like I could always best them
at every turn, in terms of gaming.
- Oh, I love that.
- And I was always better than them at it.
So I was like, hell yeah.
(actress laughing)
- You know what's so interesting?
I took flying lessons. They say sometimes-
- Did you?
- female. I did!
Because I was terrified of it
and I was trying to overcome the fear.
It didn't work. But anyway-
- I want that for that reason too.
- But it is, it's no, I didn't like it.
I don't like flying.
But I, but I did like the lesson of it.
It, but it was funny because
the, the guy kept saying
my instructor kept, Randy kept saying,
women are actually usually better at this
because of how your minds work.
- Yes.
- And how you, he's like,
I've just taught so many men
and women and there's.
So I wonder if that correlates
to like gaming world.
- A hundred per cent-
- How your brain kind of computes.
- It correlates.
I mean it's a very male-dominated
sport, on the outside,
is how people look at it.
- Yeah.
- But in actuality-
(Kelly laughing)
- I love that you call it a sport.
- Yeah. It's, yeah! It's a sport!
- You're such a gamer.
- It is a sport.
(Kelly laughing)
- It's technically an E-Sport!
- Are you sweating?
- Yeah. They call it being sweaty.
So like when-
- What?
- so when like you're playing Call of Duty
and it's really hard, they're like,
"Wow this is like a sweaty,
this is a sweaty game right now.
- You play Call of Duty?
- Yeah.
(actress laughing)
That's my game.
- Oh my God.
I've seen someone play that game.
I'm like this is an intense game.
- Oh yeah.
Yeah. It's sweaty.
- Okay. So you've said that
the way you've been treated
as a woman in the industry,
you said people are treated
like that in the game world too,
right?
- For sure.
So it is like
it is a very like a male-dominated field
in a lot of ways.
- I don't hear a lot of
females going, I'm a gamer.
I'm a, I sported out.
(Kelly laughs)
- I sported out online.
No but you know, it's funny
the, the ratio of men to women
in, in the sport is actually really high.
Like a lot of women game.
- Yeah.
- But we use male avatars
because there's kind of such an aggression
towards women within it
that a lot of us pretend to be guys.
(Kelly gasps)
Which is what I've done all the years
that I've played games.
- Wow. That sucks.
- Yeah. And so now I think
there's a lot more communication
going on about it where
people are really talking
about women getting into gaming openly.
- Yeah.
- Because our minds do
work differently than guys.
So we do have a bit of
a mental dexterity edge
that's different than the way
that a guy might play a game
and stuff like that.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. So for sure.
- I love that. I could get into
gaming 'cause you sit there.
(both laughing)
So do you feel like
that's the same situation,
like the industry you think,
have you had a lot of push
'cause you're a woman in this industry?
I had to work harder
than my male counterparts when
I was younger, especially.
- Yeah.
I mean, I think you're
definitely, I think you're, you're
at a little bit of a
disadvantage for sure.
And, and I think it, it's
hard because when you're
in an industry like this where, you know
we are putting ourselves
into the spotlight,
it can definitely come back
with a lot of people looking
at you and being like, well
you put yourself out there.
Don't you want the, you
know, the, the criticisms?
But in reality, you know
I think there's a lack of
compassion in a lot of ways.
- Yeah. Or empathy.
- Or empathy towards, yeah.
- 'Cause you're just doing what you love.
It just happens to be in this spot.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that's true.
Well it depends on who
you're talking to, I guess.
- Yeah.
- But how have you learned to
deal with those situations?
Like in, in the industry?
'Cause I feel like I didn't
have like a lot of like
friends in the industry.
Like, I don't know if I
have a ton now either,
but I just mean like, I have a lot
of like normal like working lives,
like that kind of thing like around me.
How do you deal with that?
- I mean, yeah, I've
had my two best friends
since I was, my God,
nine years old, Mia and Karina.
- Wow.
- They're like, my, my ride or dies
and, and it was really
through the pandemic
that I found like a work life balance.
I feel like I never really
had that previously.
- Yeah. It kind and forced us
all to kind of look at that.
- Yeah. A hundred percent.
Well look at everything in
our lives in so many ways.
- Yeah.
- And like for me during the pandemic,
the big one was getting out
and being in nature and going camping.
- Love
- And getting offline,
you know, in the sense.
And so I, you know, we would go camping
up in Yosemite with no
wifi, no service or nothing.
And that was kind of the
really, the big change for me.
- That was me too.
That's why I have a place I go
and I literally just got back.
And I feel so it's just
like you're refueled.
- A hundred per cent.
- Just to get outta the city
and just kind of get out of it.
It's nice.
- Yeah.
- Anybody! Get out of
any workspace you're in
like, and just kind of try
something new and different.
It's good for you.
- No matter the the field for sure.
- Yeah. Especially fresh air.
- Yes.
- I love, that's why I
like, I will do a hike
but like an easy one,
(actress laughing)
- A walk.
- I will do that.
- Some would call it a nice walk.
- You know what? I should call it a walk.
A walk in the woods.
(both laughing)
That's what I should call it.
So you've also talked about
the importance of being alone.
So I don't mind being alone either.
Like why do you think it's
I think it's good for us
to sometimes be alone.
- I, I love it.
Like for me, I honestly, I'll
like purposely go to eat alone
and kind of be on my, my own
and just surrounded by myself.
And I think the big thing is
surrounding yourself
with your own thoughts
and being able to work through
the things that come up
when you don't have the you know,
influx of constant
communication around you.
- Yeah. To be still.
- Exactly. To learn, to be still.
Because I think especially
nowadays in this world
of social media and having
our phones on us all the time
it's super easy to just
constantly get caught up
in simulation and being simulated
by everything around you.
- I p*** so many of my friends off.
I don't know if I can say
p*** off on this show.
- You just don't respond?
- But like, no, I don't respond and I
I don't mean to be rude,
but I like to be where I am.
- I know.
- And like you're with whoever
you're with at that moment
and that should be the moment, right?
- Yeah.
- And I like, I get in so much trouble.
- Because I'm not constantly
responding all the time,
but I don't wanna be that person.
- I know. I do. I do the same thing.
I mean, you know, it's
funny 'cause on one hand
like I love gaming. I love tech.
On the other hand, I have
this like trying to learn
to balance it where it's like
I don't wanna be on my phone
and I don't wanna have to
be responding to people
and I need to get outside.
And like, it's an interesting
juxtaposition that we're
caught between like
humanity and tech and how
do we like navigate that.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- And I'm sure-
- At your email going,
is someone gonna die?
No.
- No.
- So like, yeah, no one's gonna die about.
- Yeah. I'm not gonna answer
this phone call today.
- I'm just gonna watch this
movie with my kids. Yeah.
- Yeah. Exactly.
- Yeah.